if you can be yourself and create
content
so you're not acting I think you're
winning
but if you have to play somebody else to
get eyeballs where you're acting
um
and that's what gets the eyeballs where
The UU won't get the real eyeballs I
think that's a conflict that's a little
bit of a conflict so everything to me is
what happens for example let's just say
I'm I'm telling you you got to live by
these 10 rules these are the 10 values
and principles Sean you gotta live by
this and I'm your dad and I'm telling
you this and I don't live by that deep
down inside I have conflict and have
internal conflict which is the worst
kind of conflict forget about the
conflict I have with you I have internal
conflict because when there's internal
conflict everybody runs you feels it
right because you're not living in
aligned life to when I when I was
creating content and I'm trying to be
something I'm not
how do I not only am I not enjoying it
but I'm just it's not also doing good so
I don't care to be that listen I can't
help myself I love talking about
politics I'm going to keep doing that I
love capitalism I'm going to keep doing
that I love entrepreneurship I'm going
to talk about that I love you know
interviewing people who are in certain
industries that I have interest over I'm
gonna keep pursuing that topic and then
if there's an audience for it fantastic
if there's not it's all good but trying
to compromise who you are on the big
screen to get eyeballs versus
my biggest suggestion would be try to
match these two together and then listen
it doesn't mean you don't get creative
you know you want to get creative or
have a board here we'll sit down and
like you know I had a meeting with a
couple of my content creators on talent
and I'm sitting there talking to one of
them I'm saying listen why are you still
talking about this well because it's
what I stand for there's no way I cannot
talk about this I said listen that's
nine months ago people have moved on
it's over what other interests do you
have so I sat and had a two-hour meeting
with one of my content creators and I
said what bothers you we wrote it down
20 things what do you love we wrote it
down what do you hate we wrote it down
when you were a kid what interest did
you have what do you know a lot about
that I don't know do you know a lot
about the Yankees do you know a lot
about the history of animals do you like
lions did you grow up as a tell me what
hair what do you know about Middle East
did you study theology do you know a lot
about politics do you know a lot about
what the law what do you know a lot
about yesterday I'm sitting on my son my
10 year old son tells me he says daddy
do you know what that uh there's certain
sea bass that you eat that has a poison
that if you eat the sea sea bass hot
becomes cold and cold becomes hot that
you can't even have ice in your drinks
because your mouth will feel like you're
on fire I'm like what are you talking
about he says no I'm telling you like
this guy's trying to pull a prank so I
go and I research I'm like this kid is
right there's a poison that what did you
learn about this I read it in a book so
my son loves reading the 5 000 fact
books right so if he wanted to create
content he could create a fact thing he
can do different things so you know if
if you can figure right away to improve
yourself as a content creator where
talking to another guy yesterday who's
got 950 000 subs and he's been around
that number for about six months you
know how frustrating it is to be at 9
15. sure very annoying because you're
kind of like dude I'm right there at a
million but I'm like I'm annoyed right
and he's reached the limit of his
content
he's reached for his audience they don't
have interest on the same things he
talked about for the last two years
because his content is limited based on
life experiences and he no longer has
any life experiences to share that's new
they've heard all of it in 200 episodes
so now what does he do he has to figure
out a way because the audience is like
we got everything from you already now
you're trying to give us something if he
doesn't adjust he's going to be a
YouTube channel that got a million Subs
based on the videos he did not any more
interest on anything new it's a very
emotional place to be when you're there
because you're no longer getting that
attention so it is an emotional job it
is tough it is draining your insecurity
is going to come out you're going to be
going on streaks where you feel like
nobody cares anymore you're forgotten
about but if you constantly try to
recreate yourself while still staying
true to your values and principles
new audience will constantly show